the texas lawmakers make it to dc they
they host their own press conference and
during their press conference
they actually break out into song we
want to be standing there
when a new voting rights act for this
century is there and the rights that we
struggled that so many lives were taken
so much courage was demonstrated
are preserved once again i turn it back
over to you
for the questions and uh thank you very
much for
all that you and all of your colleagues
are doing here today
we will overcome we will overcome
we will never
[Music]
i cannot take any more of the boomer
larping i can now
this is what's going on now is in the
1960s you had a very consequential
social movement called
the civil rights movement and it changed
the way voting took place and it changed
a lot of a lot of the country
and today
all of these it's as though time froze
in 1965 it says that everyone is just
play acting what happened in 1965
and so they're trying to compare this
effort to
br break the law in texas to stymie
election integrity reforms
to the 1960s civil rights movement or
some other really consequential movement
don't forget
these these voting laws that are going
on around the country in many
in many instances are just restoring
protections that we had two years ago
they're not even you know we had we had
election integrity measures
then last year the liberal establishment
got rid of all of them and not all of
them but a great deal of them
and in some cases explicitly violated
the state constitution on the way
elections are supposed to be conducted
notably in pennsylvania
and now we're told that if you ever
restore any of those things again you
know those provisions that we had in
place
18 months ago if you ever do that that
that's basically jim crow
it's slavery it's racist it's just so
preposterous not just these silly texas
democrats
kamala harris defending them i do want
to first start by
making a statement about the the
legislators
in texas who are showing extraordinary
courage and commitment i
met with them when many of them traveled
to washington dc we
sat down and had an extensive
conversation in the roosevelt room in
the white house
and i applaud them standing
for the rights of all americans and all
texans
to express their voice through their
vote unencumbered
i will say that that they are
they are leaders who are marching in the
path that so many others before did
when they fought and many died for our
right to vote
so what what kamala harris is saying is
that
if you have to show an id to vote this
is a measure supported by
a huge number of people including by a
number of polls the majority of black
people this has become a
racialized issue but but even the
majority of black people according to
many polls
support these sorts of things then then
you're disenfranchising people you are
you're disenfranchising illegal aliens
you're disenfranchising
political hacks you're just
disenfranchising people who shouldn't be
voting
that's that's what you're doing here and
she's saying that you know she applauds
these texas lawmakers
make no mistake the texas lawmakers are
subverting democracy not just because
they're
trying to get rid of election integrity
measures but because they're violating
the law
the people of texas elected their
representatives their legislators
the legislators are now pursuing their
legislative agenda
the democrats because there's no legal
way for them to stop this just flee the
state which is against the law and by
the way
which is going to result in there being
arrested so governor abbott came out
he was not having any anything to do
with this he said that they're in
violation of the law the minute they
land back in texas they'll be arrested
they'll be brought back to the capitol
but that actually probably won't even be
necessary now
because a few democrats were pried off
they've now voted with the republicans
they couldn't withstand the public
pressure to do so
and the election integrity measures will
be restored
at the total uh
[Music]
disadvantage to the all these democrats
you know
all of these democrats are are
desperately trying to prevent these
kinds of measures not just in texas but
everywhere
why what are they so afraid of why
are democrats so insistent on making
permanent the corrupt election practices
that came up
during the 2020 covid lockdowns this
isn't just happening at the state level
this isn't just happening
in kamala harris's press conferences
this is becoming a priority
of the biden administration
hey you we're not allowed to talk so
much on youtube anymore they don't like
some of the things we say
so you've got to make sure that you ring
that bell and you subscribe
because sometimes people do that but
they still don't get the notification so
make sure you do that head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
you can subscribe
to the michael knowles show and you can
order right now
my book the number one national
best-selling
non-new york times listed because
they're a bunch of jerks
speechless controlling words controlling
minds we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]